mind your decisions I'm presh tal Walker
consider the numbers 1 2 3 & 4 there are
six possible products that can be made
by pairing these numbers these will be
illustrated below now to explain the
puzzle I'm thinking of four positive
numbers there are six possible products
from pairing the numbers I will reveal
five of the products have values of two
three four five and six what is the
value of the sixth product pause if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
before I get to the solution I'll admit
this was a tricky puzzle and I did not
solve it myself but I thought the
solution was very clever so let's go
back to our original example of 1 2 3 &
4
the trick is to consider the product of
1 2 3 & 4 which is equal to 24 now let's
look at the product from pairing these
numbers let's exchange these two pairs
look in the very first line if we take
the product of these pairs we have 2
times 12 which is equal to 24 this is
also true in the second line we have 3
times 8 which is equal to 24 and in the
very last line we have 4 times 6 which
is equal to 24 so we found three
different ways to get the product of the
four original numbers so suppose the
numbers are ABCD and we only know the
product of the pair's so we have four
unknown numbers but we can still make
the product ABCD in three different ways
that's the key insight furthermore
suppose BC is the unknown pair well if
we write that as X we still have two
different ways that we can get the
product ABCD and the other pair ad which
is not listed will pair with the unknown
product to get ABCD so now let's solve
our problem we know that the pairs are
equal to 2 3 4 5 & 6 so we need to
consider pairing each of these and then
examining the product of each of these
pairs we're hoping to get two values
that are equal because that will be the
product of the four original numbers
when we examine these products we have
two ways that we can make 12 so this
will reveal that 12 is the product of
the four original numbers we have 2
times 6 2 which is 12 3 times 4 which is
12 and so 5 is the product which is not
involved therefore five times
X
must be equal to 12 and that six product
will be equal to 12 over five or 2.4 and
that's our answer now for a challenge
what could the four original numbers be
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support